like what Magnus has done at this moment
and John came up to me and literally
held me by the throat and said don't
tell me you decline to draw and I said
John I'm just waiting for him to move if
he hangs his queen I'm going to accept
the draw because it meant the gold medal
in the first place I see very nice
that's that's a funny image because John
is just like such a sweet gu sweetheart
you never imagine him holding me by the
throat right he was in town actually
because he's um curating um helping with
the uh patorski
exhibition and that's in the first floor
of the World Chess Hall of Fame it's
actually there's a preview right now in
the full exhibition is going to be
opening later in the month so um pretty
pretty uh pretty impressive guy you know
he's uh an expert in chess history he's
captain of numerous World Championship
world team championship and Olympic
teams um but I know he's also a personal
friend of yours sure and I have
witnessed Gary Kasparov I was once in
Prague when Gary Kasparov literally
played a simultaneous against the entire
Czech uh uh Olympic team and this
simultaneous was really a fine fine
Affair and at One Moment One of the
Czech players offered Gary a draw a draw
that clinched the match for Gary and
Gary actually gave it a lot of
consideration before he finally accepted
and he was looking for a maximum result
but he did accept whereas what we're
seeing right now is Magna still pressing
and saying okay let's just take it to a
finish it would be great to hear what
Gary thinks about this actually I mean
now I would love to hear from him we've
got we've got Twitter is absolutely
exploding with admiration for Magnus
Carlson's decision uh fans all over the
world uh are pretty excited by this
somebody said maybe Carlson has a bonus
that we don't know about that's an
interesting uh preposition from one of
his his many sponsors uh I I never even
thought of that um somebody else uh
tweeted that
um
Leon
$70,000 whatever that translation please
translation translation yeah I can't
believe Magnus Carson declined to draw
against Lana Ronan um when he could just
win $70,000 and win the first prize and
we do have uh we have uh listeners from
all over the world and some of them
actually tweet in other languages and
makes me wish that uh
we could read all of them over there
exactly let me assure you one thing
because uh this I'm I have absolutely uh
full confidence about when Rex and joy
Tony uh were setting up the whole event
they wanted all the prize money there's
no extra payments to the players or any
of that stuff they wanted it all up
front above board everybody could see so
there unfortunately there's not a Bobby
Fisher prize if there was we would have
told you in other words if you made a
maximum score you get a bonus there's no
bonus in this event for Magnus if he
wins it with four and a half or five or
what have you uh it's still 70,000 and
let's take a look at some uh some moves
that have been played here we got we're
actually uh close to move 50 now wow so
um let me close and refresh window the
time is continuing to become an issue we
got four minutes for aonan and Carlson
with five all right so we'll go back to
the game position and Maurice is anxious
to share some thoughts Maurice what have
we got indeed Jen and yesz now Houdini 3
is going nuts because it looks as though
Carlson is simply winning cold on the
board it's giving a big Edge for Carlson
after the last move by black king to d8
and it says after Knight C4 aonian is
going to be destroyed Knight C4
attacking the Knight and the Rook on D6
and it's saying this position now unless
I have the wrong position let me just
call up the the board position and it is
looking like he can play KN C4
everything looks correct so I do have
that same position on my other analysis
board so let's go back to that Knight C4
attacking the Knight on A5 that's a
whole piece he's about to win and after
Knight takes on C4 Pawn takes Chasing
The Rook back to B8 and now the move C5
and it looks as though he's coming down
the board with Rook takes A6 putting
pressure on the night on C6 and it's
saying that the only move the only move
is Rook takes Knight on D3 just to stay
in the fight Rook takes Knight King
takes and then A5 to try to stay in the
fight why does he have to do that let's
take a look now if he just drops his
Rook back to
D7 then instead Rook takes A6 and the
Knight on C6 has to move and if Knight
to D4 this Pawn on E5 is going to be a
problem moves like Rook to A8 forcing
more exchanges and then the B4 Pawn is
hanging incredible position actually
this line takes takes and Knight takes
A1 runs into Rook to B8 King to E7 and
then simply Rook takes on B4 and the
Knight on A1 is trapped incredible lines
but it looks as though if Magnus now
plays this move Knight to
C4 after King d8 he will be winning at
least have a big Advantage maybe that
chain sack will give aonia some chances
to fight back but we're waiting to see
if magnos plays that move because he
would win clear and his draw declining
that draw will look like simply a bold
and genius maneuver so we'll see if he
plays that move in the next few minutes
he actually has not few minutes to play
he only has five minutes on his clock to
close out the singfield cup back to you
Jen andas thank you dramatic turn and
he's played your move Maurice he has
played Knight C4 Knight C4 changing the
character of the position so instead of
that Knight H3 G5 all along when Magnus
declined that draw offer and played
Knight D1 he was already envisioning
these kinds of things Knight B2 Knight
C4 and perhaps if leavon had his King
over defending the A6 Pawn um things
wouldn't be as dire well at the moment
the leavon has put his King over here on
d8 and the and the line of play that
Maurice has shown us is that in case of
Trades and this looks like a forced
trade I must say
The Rook being attacked The Rook dropped
back just as Maurice uh suggested Rook
back to to B8 now this very important
sanzo in between move not capturing the
pawn at once but first uh dislodging
this Rook so that in case it drops back
Rook takes A6 would be devastating
coming with Tempo against the Knight and
essentially Black's position is
collapsing as White's Rooks are far more
effective than Black's Rooks so
remarkable dramatic uh well because the
E5 Pawn is also hanging so IND the event
of Knight to D4 in that line that we
were seeing we saw that how that night
got
trapped uh no for for these guys they do
it routinely ex exactly that's true this
is routine yeah and uh though with not
that much time in the clock it is it is
interesting to to wonder how much of
this Carlson thought of when he played
night D1 D1 he did uh take a long think
before he declined that draw offer right
and I wonder if um if black had kept his
King
over6 yeah kind of protecting that pawn
on A6 how much that would have changed
matters would this Knight B2 idea still
be strong because the problem is that
you know in this line with Knight C4 we
can't take and move our Rook anywhere
effective so maybe it would still be a
really good idea well it still wasn't
clear to me why uh he didn't play Rook
got a couple more moves so nice um so
you might want to try refreshing of
course which I'll do instantly pardon
and to remind everyone there is no third
time control here so the time they have
on the clock is what they've got 4
minutes four minutes to five minutes KN
takes C4 was played Knight takes C4 this
and Leon feeling the heat now and The
Rook on um B5 under threat we're
expecting that it will drop back to B8
four minutes for Carlson 2 minutes for
Ronan the players relying upon their 30
seconds bonus in increment this is where
uh Maurice was saying that after C5 the
computer recommended uh sacrificing a
rook or an exchange pardon me with King
takes D3 this Pawn is hanging and after
A5 something like King C4 this looks
like a very clear Advantage for white
this extra exchange white is about ready
to slide his Rook over to the D1 Square
seizing the open file and and definitely
the position is in oh yes and
technically technically black being up a
pawn but not being able to really
utilize them all being very very well
blockaded
exactly wow dramatic turnaround I I just
spoke a few minutes or earlier when I
was talking about Magnus off the board
and it's how it's impossible not to be a
fan of his because he's such a likable
fellow but now his on the board manner
of playing for a win regardless
regardless I just play for a win I think
with what he's done today is he's
electrified the world of Chess this is a
incredible decision and as Marie said
the likes of which he's never seen in
his career well history being made here
in St l in so many different ways the
strongest tournament in American history
and the the last one before Magnus plays
in on and now this exactly this
incredible uh declining of a draw in a
situation where a wind yields the same
prizes as a draw exactly and I think uh
the organizers uh Rex Tony uh Joy all
the staff here have to be really really
proud in a sense because this is an
extraordinary compliment that Magnus is
giving the organizers by saying you know
you guys have made the tournament
conditions here such a great tournament
I'm going to reward you with my very
best effort oh that's true I totally
agree with that and uh Rook to B8 been
played sorry yeah go ahead I mean if
people weren't weren't excited about a
sinkfield cup part two um now before
this then they're going to be even more
thrilled about it now exactly um wow wow
so we we are expecting uh this very
important little nuanced move this Tempo
against this black Rook which is
currently protecting the Knight on C6
this C5 I think is one of the keys
uh to White having an advantage in
Maurice am I right about that that C5 is
a key move at this moment yeah you're
definitely right about that C5 is a bone
cruncher and we should note leavon
aronian at 121 Magnus Carlson at 4
minutes so a lot to play for lot of
complications still remaining and leavon
with only a minute and a half he keeps
getting those 30 seconds but boy 30
seconds don't seem like a lot when
you're in this kind of position under
this kind of pressure from the world's
best player and C5 it looks like has
been played on the board and leavon
forced to think about it you know he
doesn't want to sacrifice an exchange
and go into that situation where he's
just getting squeezed but what else to
do and you see him there with a clock
ticking his chin he's he's thinking
about what to do and he did not take on
D3 but this move Rook back to D7 it will
be disastrous this variation the
computer has already showed is dead
busted for him after this move Rook to
D7 which was just hard to realize just
how bad it might get Rook takes on A6
that looks like that's all she wrote
there's hardly anything to do now Rook
takes D3 no longer works for anything
because the a pawn is gone so the breach
has definitely uh been made in the black
position and the only line we could look
at now is this move Knight D4 and leavon
has to hope he got some little cheapos
right here but this sweet move Rook to
A8 is going to be all she wrote yes this
is incredible how this kid has broken
through and shown his class amazing I I
mean no words it's just simply
amazing yeah have chess fans all over
the world cheering here we are running
out of accolades aren't we H yeah indeed
we're going to have to save some of them
for the world champions here let's hope
although I know many of our our
listeners are also rooting for on also
has plenty of fans but I'll tell you
what Magnus Carlson has earned a lot
more super fans now I mean of fans
before now are um understanding what the
hoopla is all about and why he gets such
a great we do have a couple more moves
in it seems like uh we we should
probably refresh the board here all
right let me close my window and open it
once um instead of that move Knight D4
which looked so natural but failed
because the knight uh was getting
trapped in the corner in that um
tactical variation it looks like aonan
has played uh the move B is that uh I'm
trying I'm getting they played the move
B3
after Rook takes A6 B3 so now there's a
Knight hanging on C6 wild move oh my I
don't get this one bit and what am I
missing oh I see there's a cheapo
Maurice mentioned cheapos uh so after
after this we're we're threatening uh
Rook B1 right and we're getting a this
is what uh aonian is banking on that
he'll have all right well let's let's go
it looks like we have even more moves
occurring in the board okay what has
occurred Jen I'll follow you uh we after
B3 what did white play B3 work B3 work
take C6 was played and pawn take C2
indeed so trying to come up with those
ideas like Rook B1 to save the game but
instead of Knight C1 um why can't white
just play something okay so if if we
play Rook C1 then there's Rook B3 so
that also saves uh that that idea um so
instead of Rook C1 well Rook C1 Rook B3
is what you mentioned yeah oh but even
here we can start we can start nibbling
on pawns right Maurice is getting
himself all excited he's saying after
takes on C2 there's a funky move here
Knight takes
E5 no no no no not Knight takes E5 I be
you saying Rook toook takes E6 just
start snatching pawns right away and in
case of Rook B1 we've got a back rank
Checkmate oh how sweet it is ooh so Rook
takes E6 instead and in case of Rook
takes D3 check King takes D3 now we're
getting into a straight Rook ending with
all of these black pawns falling yes
your idea was that if I if I checked you
you you had a little uh King D7 but I
also could have maybe thrown in the move
uh oh that was winning what's that I
have a move uh c6's to throw in at some
moment well no after you mean after Rook
to A8 sha yes King D7 King
takes on B1 so after King takes E6 King
B1 we're off a rook and there is no Rook
ending to look at that's just an entire
rook and that would be resignation on
the spot so that doesn't work either so
this move Rook takes E6 looks like a
finale wow that looks like kapo um and
it looks like Magnus did not play Rook
takes E6 that he has played a different
movie he played Knight
E1 with the idea that if something comes
to um no so you got you got to take back
so now after Knight E1 I suppose the
idea is that after Knight takes E2 The
Rook on A1 is defended precisely so so
if he plays Rook B1 you can just snatch
that pawn and C2 and you're up you're up
a
horse okay all right whoa uh Maurice
this is getting exciting I know the
players are down to their increment but
uh you've got a beat on what's going on
Maurice take it well Magnus did miss
this move Rook takes E6 a spectacular
move keeping all the tactics alive he
would have been winning instead he
played the more conservative Knight to
E1 and after King E7 he just snatched
the pawn off the board and all you got
to do is Count uh pawns are even you got
couple of Rooks on the board and there's
just a big old night it's just a big old
night and that's it so we would expect
leavon to resign at any moment the only
reason he might make some moves is
because of the time pressure but I would
keep the camera on leavon right now for
the moment because he is done there's no
chance for him he looks like he has
played the move Rook to B3 check and
Magnus dropped his King back and back to
E2 it looks like but leavon is not
thinking really this is what happened
but he's still making moves if Magnus
doesn't think it's too early to draw or
that it is too early to draw then leavon
is probably thinking well I guess it's
too early to resign let let's make some
moves and see what happens next maybe
the kid will make a blunder but he knows
that this position is cold cut busted
and he's got to be embarrassed but he's
still just making moves moving against
Rook over now to A2 the moment has
passed clearly if Magnus keeps his cool
and just plays solidly he's going to be
the winner by a large margin of the
singfield cup right and uh his his his
world ranking I mean his rating is going
to just be his world ranking of course
is set in stone but his rating will
continue to rise and um you know maybe
one day he'll he'll he'll reach 2900
right well he's on his way this is a
boost Bo indeed yeah I mean against the
number two rated player in the world um
fantastic and he's playing you saw that
he was playing some moves pretty rapidly
so we are likely to see a result um
pretty soon and I want to remind
everyone that we are going to have
Magnus Carlson down here to talk about
his victory but we're also going to have
a press conference 45 minutes after the
result and I believe we have a result oh
no I not I saw uh pardon me I got myself
excited go wrong because this Knight B2
Knight C4 idea was was looked pretty
pretty strong do you think shuttling
that King over at the wrong moment that
was it but even with a king on B7 night
you4 would probably be a pretty powerful
idea no it wasn't that not as much Jen I
think well before we before we back and
and certainly Magnus will have some
thoughts on that as well right we won't
go through with the post morm quite yet
uh but there is still a an issue this
Rook um on C6 well no no it's also an
entire night uh a whole piece I should
say yeah that Rook can be can be rescued
sometime Rook A6 Knight B4 it's ideas no
no no question even you know maybe
Knight B4 Knight D3 kind of deal going
on the king E3 um well I must say just
ah he's played F4 even better and it
look like leavon might be about to
resign but instead grabbing another
score sheet as we have reached move 60
move 60 we do have these moves uh Let me
refresh so what's the time at the moment
uh Jen it looks like we've got uh just a
under a minute for leavon but of course
uh this position not hard to make quick
moves in I mean he's totally lost and
you know just trying to out of inertia
he's playing you think yeah maybe just
still kind of sometimes people keep
playing even when they're lost because
they're thinking about what went wrong
just kind of adjusting to the shock sure
there is a big shock and there is there
is a Time situation just three minutes
for Carlson and uh as you pointed out
the Rook on C6 not yet escaped but uh
Carlson has just played the move F4 very
confidently um Grandmaster Ashley your
thoughts on how long this game's GNA go
well clearly Carlson's winning and the
issue though is how do you win is it a
win yet you know sometimes GMS resign
well often GMS resign we're down a peace
the game's over ought to be over out of
respect we resign my students always say
what what you resigning for I don't see
a win so what you're up a piece can we
play some some bit some moves and let's
see what happens and so leavon and and
Carlson they're I think quitting
themselves quite well they're showing to
an American audience we're Fighters we
will play to The Bitter End and although
he knows he's losing Anything Could
Happen some kind of trick might pop up
he's not happy but also you know what
he's in the same situation anyway
nothing changes for leavon he went for
it so if he loses by resigning or by
playing some moves show me we're in the
show me state after all show me show me
what the win is and Carson by the way
now is actually obligated to winning I
mean there's that psychological thing
right it's not like he can suddenly
offer a draw in this position that would
be completely bizarre he's almost
obligated to winning and so he has to
find the moves to finish this off and
for the moment his night is not showing
anything it's on C3 it's on C2 looking
to get into the game so we'll see just
how long it takes before bnus finds the
clear plan that puts black completely
away in this game Maurice thank you I
think I found it I see a
checkmating uh plan for white it begins
with the move F4 F5 so that that after
the intention my intention is that after
G takes F5 e takes F5 King takes F5 Rook
F1 check if you move your king to G4 I
want to take this Pawn on E6 if you take
my knight I want to check you from
behind and I've driven you to the old
classical double Rook check that would
be a sweet
finishi C wouldn't it wouldn't it yeah
so I think this move F4 F5 closes the
deal and puts the finishing touch and a
beautiful Finishing Touch on the
singfield cup I think that does it
amazing what Magnus Carlson did here
with a a bad opening we and we know we
will be talking about historic events
and historic moments uh kids are going
to ask you in the future you know what
was it like when Magnus declined an
offer of a draw oh God and what great
you know a lot this video is going to be
archived so what a great uh little
classroom lesson right right just take
this down take this down uh sadly we
well I I think sadly we didn't see that
particular finish instead um Magnus has
spotted a different uh checkmating idea
he's captured this Pawn on E5 and now
he's maneuvering his Knight over so KN
E1 now he played Knight E1 protecting
this Knight Pro pardon me protecting
this Pawn on G to and is aspiring for
Knight F3 check uh a different approach
from the one I just showed but probably
very effective E6 is going to be a goner
right and there could be a rook coming
to F1 as well to join the party and also
it's kind of Shifting his forces over to
the king side where black will be
totally overwhelmed exactly I must say I
did like that F4 F5 oh that was yeah it
was a pretty finish wasn't it and and we
have another move Rook A3 check Rook A3
check okay and Maurice uh thoughts on
how this is going to
end well I liked your move as well yes I
think that Carlson is saying my night is
free now it's in the game this is the
only question he needed to answer once
the Knight enters the game it's over I'm
not sure the mate was forced but he's
very clear on the fact once my night
starts working I'm going to show you
what an extra piece does and he's very
confident now he can play these moves in
his sleep he can lean back and just
Blitz out the rest no trick
possible even for black where is the
trick I mean it's just not even here no
way in the world leavon survives this
and he's looking around desperately for
some kind of something but it's just not
here anymore two Rooks too linear too
obvious and to dead is leavon aronian
right now terrific fight though but it's
all over unbelievable fight unbelievable
throughout the tournament throughout the
tournament and and uh looks like he's
played Rook to D2 check you've called
these before in your broadcast Spike
checks Spike checks now this uh this
makes the the move Knight F3 actually a
fork threat mhm and uh expecting uh
Magnus to drop back with his King by the
way that would cover all the threats and
now a new look like King G1 was played a
new threat has appeared Rook takes C7 as
well as Knight F3 check this is over
over over at this moment moment that's
right I mean let me make sure that the I
don't know if it was king1 he play King
F1 rather so he played King F1 and um
staying cozy with the Knight by the
way over protected so Rook A2 just leads
to nothing right there's no so uh
instead it looks like like leavon has
just dropped his Rook back to D7 to
defend against both the Knight F3 check
threat and The Rook takes C7 thre well
Magnus has it all here I mean and
knight3 check played anyway absolutely
that's That's cold blooded cuz yeah I
mean if4 is going to uh lose the E6 Pawn
correct and then and more more pawns are
going to f fall more ponies more ponies
no this I think that this is a a very
very good uh moment after we would see a
move like King takes E4 Rook takes E6
for leavon to give it a rest uh it's
over so you think this is a time for
leavon to resign um and we keep thinking
he might but he's going um instead he
played a king it looks like he played
King to F4 king after Knight F3 he
checked he played King F4 instead and
then the pawn was captured on E6 and I'm
not sure what we see after
that more uh more things are
dropping yeah maybe uh King G5 yes we
see G
okay so Ponda G5 wow okay he's still
leavon is not ready to hang
up
um yet well he ready to play after Pawn
takes G5 H4 and
H3 but that's not going to work here no
so just just taking it to the very
Bitter End maybe uh you know he's
returning magnus's decline of the draw
offer with a trying to play it out to
checkm to to show the kids at home a
sweet Al you don't think so but he's
getting a lot closer to that than you
would have thought yes uh I I certainly
didn't expect that once as Maurice said
you know once White's night shifts over
gets into the game you're just playing a
piece up uh White prong there was a
capture on G5 followed by a king
Invasion on G3 King so we've got we're
up to date with the position at the
moment with after King G3 so just
playing along trying to play H4 and H3
if only he had another night wow I'm
surprised that leavon is playing it on
this long but okay I mean that certainly
is prerogative well if I were white I
probably uh would just maneuver my Rook
to F6 so that in case of a say an H4
I'll drop with my knight back and I'm
setting myself up for ideas like Rook F3
check and just winning the game but
there's so many ways to win the game you
can just play G6 threatening Rook F7 the
G Pawn is queening exactly this or
nighting yeah or nighting I like that
night me I don't think so I I like the
promotion and let's see what do we
have has been played so uh technical
Mastery of grandmas Saran uh being
echoed by Magnus Carlson uh
unfortunately you don't need any
Grandmaster leag techque here I mean
this is really really as hopeless as
I've seen and it looks like we're
following your move as well work to A2
um by leavon so hitting a hitting on G2
but as you as you pointed out Knight E1
is available to him right well that's
indeed uh desirable you defend the pawn
on G2 this King on
G3 well it's not threatening or but once
you get the Knight out of the way the F3
square is available for the rook and
this is just so hopeless my goodness I'm
really surprised that uh leavon is
sharing his tragic a agony
uh so long we have a comment from
Michael Waters who says that and we have
it and there it is Magnus Carlson is the
sinkfield Cup winner the champion he's
creeping closer to 2900 we have a
comment on Twitter that Magnus Carlson
turned Les's draw offer down that's by
Michael Waters because he previously
said he wanted to be world champion and
2900 by the end of 2013 and he gets one
step closer with his victory at the
singfield cup leaving him far ahead of
his Rivals and securing the
$70,000 the trophy and more importantly
I mean making a fabulous impression to
fans all over the world Jen I don't
think it gets any better than this at 22
years old I me give me a break Maurice
what's your thoughts on that one
absolutely incredible what a moment for
chess what a great champion this kid is
already and he really sent a signal to
the rest of the world what kind of
fighter He Is We already knew he was a
tremendous fighter but I don't think
this situation has ever occurred to him
and he willingly embraced it he's turned
down a draw when really this Victory it
actually did nothing else maybe the
rating points as you mentioned Jen did
nothing else to secure his place in this
tournament he won the game or drew the
game it was the exact same thing but he
chose to risk it all to play on in this
position and instead of taking the draw
go about his business and win and he's
acting now like you know yeah I was
always at the beach it was just just the
way I do incredible moment for chess
history really historic proportions to
see something like this happen I'm I'm
thrilled to have been a part of it and I
can't wait to interview him and talk
about this moment for him and see what
his thoughts are just just astonishing
really and there's some people who
actually criticized him when he said you
know you should keep playing he I've
heard a comment saying that he was just
saying that it's bogus he's just really
trying to to speak to Anon about this
kind of uh this kind of situation might
occur and I'm trying to intimidate you
what do you say now I mean this guy is
is the real
deal a hero absolutely and uh it's it's
great because everyone watching this
especially our American audience who
tuning in because it's a sink field CP
are just you know going to be you know
more not just fans of Carlon but they
might be bigger fans of Chess after this
you know put more passion and energy
into the game because of this inspiring
performance um I also like the way uh
somebody came up with a moniker um Carl
Zen that's a really good one I never
heard that before but he does he does
look very Zen while he's playing totally
relaxed no stress here um and a very
deserving champion of the singfield cup
exactly and as we get uh set up with the
mics for for our in studio guest again
I'll just say uh what a thrill what a
pleasure it is always to be with you Jen
uh to everybody on our film crew Studio
sound fantastic video to the organizers
and most especially to the fans thank
you you've all been terrific and by the
way if you do see Hikaru in the street
do give him a cheer uh it's very very
meaningful and we'll switch now to
Maurice and leavon
aronian
thanks y with leavon aronian who put up
a terrific fight in the final game but
came up short in clear third place
leavon welcome to the show thanks this
was a really difficult game for you it
seemed you needed of course a win in
order to have any chances and you put up
an amazing fight where did it go
wrong uh well I had a big advantage and
I played like an idiot I mean I don't
need to play Knight B7 I just can play
Knight B5 Knight to C3 at Knight to D4
should be technically winning but then I
just anyway just played all the wrong
ideas all the wrong moves cuz I I just
felt that I have to win immediately
which was really silly just put the
Knight on C3 Knight on D4 and it's I
don't know I don't think it's defendable
for white we had noticed this idea
ourselves and we're a bit surprised you
took an A5 why did you you said say you
had to win immediately what was the
feeling going on when you playing I just
blundered 91 cuz I felt that I just take
and then uh Rook A1 Rook E4 and Knight
E1 came as a shocker and then I started
playing ridiculous moves I mean I should
be better anyway but it's already once
after F3 is very solid and of course I
mean uh losing that position it's just
embarrassing were you shocked when he
played the move when when you offered
the draw and he declined it was that a
surprise for you not really cuz I mean
it's clear that this is Dwight was
playing
already so but he I mean he would have
won 70 grand Cole just saying yes to a
draw offer and he there is a chance he
might blunder after all why did he play
on yeah but we're not really playing for
money here we're playing for you
know we're playing chess cuz you have to
be
objective indeed well thank you so much
for your fighting spirit and your cander
and honesty and congratulations on your
third play finish we look forward to
seeing more of you in the United States
it was really an honor and a pleasure to
have you to host you here uh in St Louis
and best of luck in your tournaments for
the rest of the year thanks number two
in the world of Honor ronian third place
finish at the singfield cup back to you
Jen andz well thank you Maurice and I
must say once again and that I find uh
leavon to be you know just a wonderful
man a breath of fresh air if you will in
the Chess World very open uh very
approachable uh an enjoyable interview
at all times and somebody I just like
sharing meals with I mean it's nice to
have him great conversational indeed
indeed uh very very much so uh the final
position I just I hadn't noticed that
the knight in fact had gone to the
square E5 and as we get uh miked up with
um our tournament winner I think the
idea that this Knight coming to E5 had
in mind was that after Rook D2 check
King H4 check King takes the Knight yeah
the Knight comes to Fork rook and king
and that was ultimately why leavon
recognized that his situation was
hopeless he knew that already of course
that seeing this variation forced him to
resign now to remind everyone we have a
press conference in 45 minutes after our
interview and it's going to be really
exciting we're going to have the trophy
ceremony so you're going to want to
catch that as well um but with no
further Ado you know I just heard um
some some like really Ruck Applause we
can hear it in the basement people
applauding all over the club and
certainly at lers in the Hall of Fame
for a very deserving Champion number one
in the world Magnus Carlson and the
winner of the first singfield cup he's
with Maurice
Ashley thanks jayen we are with the
world number one player Magnus Carlson
after a scintillating Victory here in
the final round of the singfield cup
Magnus first of all congratulations
thank you Magnus it looked like you were
suffering through this game I mean you
play this variation in the real Lopez
and it looked like black had taken over
the position were you concerned at some
point that you might lose somewhere in
the early middle game maybe around move
30 absolutely completely outplayed me in
the middle game and I was really worried
about my position because I all I can do
is um is waight uh fortunately my
position still has some uh you know
inherit solidity and
uh uh that's what uh saved me indeed
there's a moment he took on A5 when he
played Knight takes A5 he could have
maneuvered his Knight to B5 and then to
C3 were you worried about that maneuver
maybe a knight another night's dropping
on the the D4 square instead of taking
on A5 oh yeah absolutely um I I thought
he'd move around perhaps take the pawn
later I think perhaps he had
overestimated this resource Rook D4
maybe he' missed my idea of Knight D1
Knight D3 and then my position is reason
reasonably solid and I think I should
hold Now by then when you're holding
everyone's thinking okay this is a draw
and then he offered you a draw the cup
70 grand and you said no yeah that was a
stunning moment for us why did you say
no at this moment when you could only
play for less as opposed to the same
thing if you just accepted a
draw well you know I I thought he'd lost
control by then completely and I I
really didn't see the harming in
continuing a little bit because I didn't
see how he could possibly improve his
position while I have some little plans
of probing both on uh on the king side
and on the the queen side uh fortunately
he he collapsed pretty pretty easily
there but you had nothing to gain I mean
this was a moment you had absolutely
nothing to except of course the win a
few rating points I mean obviously that
is a plus but you also could have
potentially blundered I don't think I've
ever seen yaser saying the same a player
have all that just being handed to him
and he says you know what I'll get it my
way was that in your mind at all that
you really wanted to win the game as
opposed to just draw well part of the
reason is I I simply wanted to play
chess here in this tournament and I
didn't have much of an opportunity to do
to do that uh in the first part of the
games I mean first part of this game I
was just defending and I I thought when
I finally had an opportunity when I
finally had the better position I needed
to try and and use that you made a quote
last year that we've shown in the
broadcast that you don't believe draw
offers should happen in games uh we've
seen this happen of course in
tournaments where people take draws in
three moves is this part of your
philosophy of Chess that it should be a
fighting game as opposed to all these
draw offers we've seen in the past yeah
absolutely um I made some bad decisions
of refusing
draws um in in the past um in this
tournament when when a draw was offered
uh in in all cases the position was
completely dead so it wasn't a big deal
but uh
um it was a little bit of a gamble but I
thought I'm I'm not risking any too much
anyway and W winning the last game would
be so sweet so indeed absolutely you
have any thoughts on the organization of
this tournament yeah I'm very happy with
uh with everything uh it's it's been a
great week and I hope to be back someday
will you be back is that your intention
D um it all depends on on the dates but
um uh I'm really I'm really hoping to
well thanks so much a final thought this
is your last game before the world
championship what will you be doing
between now and then what should we
expect as you go for the world
championship title well I'll be
fine-tuning my my game a bit obviously
working on openings uh and such um but I
feel that I'm playing
relatively good at least so uh I I don't
have too many worries there
well thanks so much for your play here
for your fighting spirit and
congratulations in being the champion of
the inaugural singfield cup thank you
world number one Magnus Carlson
cementing his legacy so far and trying
to do so as maybe world champion in
chenai will be following him as should
you back to you Jen andas well a
spectacular or as Magnus says sweet
final game before he faces aan in India
for the world championship really
thrilling for all of us to um be
watching these games and commenting on
them for the last week I've had an
absolute blast I really wish that this
was not the last day but I'm enthused to
hear that Magnus is excited to come back
absolutely and in the words of Jackie
Gleason How Sweet It Is How Sweet It Is
what a way to end the inaugural event
here in St Louis the the singfield cup
and Magnus the Magnificent just running
out of accolades he really
performed great yes in 45 minutes we're
going to have our press conference um so
that's about 10 minutes after 5 I uh
urge you to uh log on a little early so
you make sure that you can catch the
interviews with Magnus and the other
players will be there there will be a
trophy ceremony you're not going to want
to miss that and more insights into this
um fantastic inaugural Edition and we
have uh one final word from Grandmaster
Mar
Ashley Jen it's been an absolute
pleasure to be a part of this broadcast
team like you said I wish there were
more can we come back tomorrow are there
more games maybe we start the tournament
over again a tremendous tournament up
and down the organization of the
tournament Rex and jinny singfield what
classy people should support chess Joy
Bray and Tony Rich everyone who's part
of the crew uh Randy sfi's crew Winkler
Productions just I mean up and down it's
been a fantastic tournament and then the
players wow to watch these guys no
wonder we're fans I mean it's incredible
to watch the top players play chess in
an era of Fighting Chess yeah you and I
have been around when you know plus one
plus two and br's happy now players want
to win every game let's fight and
leading the charge is Magnus Carlson if
uh you weren't a fan of him before or
even if you were he's just taking it to
another level it's it's a great future
for chess and I'm thrilled to be able to
watch it back to you guys agreed I I
don't think it's I at the risk of being
hyperbolic this could be a new era for
chess and it's just thrilling to see it
happen in St Louis where so much work
has been put into the promotion of the
game it's just Such a Pity that bent
Larson isn't around because his fighting
Spirit I'm seeing magnified uh in this
generation of grand Masters and I'm sure
he would be thrilled I can't leave the
broadcast without saying what a pleasure
it's been uh working alongside you Jen
you're a great anchor lady and I won't
use the word uh in the title of your
book but thank you Jen I enjoyed every
moment yes it was wonderful thank you
Grand Masters Maurice Ashley and yaser
Saran so much fun working with both of
you and I'd also like to thank Spectrum
Studios Winkler Productions and fox for
recognizing chess as a sport as we know
it is of course all all the staff here
at the St Louis chess club and the World
Chess Hall of Fame across the street and
the fans all across the world for
showing the sink that showing the sink
fields and the whole Chess World that
this event was worth putting on even at
a pretty late notice and we just uh
couldn't thank you enough and uh keep
playing chess right and stay with us
we'll be back in 45 minutes for the
press conference here at the singfield
cup where Magnus Carlson world number
one is the
champion